bonjour et bienvenue à tous alors c'est
évidemment le discours d' emmanuel
macron qui va nous occuper aujourd'hui
largement que pensez vous de cette
opération déminage
le président de la république at il
convaincu
nous allons débattre avec vous avec nos
quatre invités que vous découvrirez dans
un instant autre sujet le torchon qui
brûle entre gérald darmanin et les
sénateurs les couteaux sont sortis entre
le ministre du budget et ses anciens
amis de la droite le vote d'une
déduction fiscale a mis le feu aux
poudres
alors qui a raison qui a tort nous
verrons tout cela enfin une question sur
ses bébés génétiquement modifiés né en
chine sont ils les bébés du futur
protégé grâce à cette technique contre
des maladies graves ou au contraire le
produit d'une dérive éthique d'ailleurs
condamné hier par la communauté
scientifique nous allons voir tout cela
bonjour le site schmidt
bonjour merci beaucoup de nous avoir
rejoints vous êtes coprésident de la
guilde european foundation fondation
européenne sur l'écologie vous êtes
aussi l'auteur de la france résiste tel
à l'écologie c'est paru aux éditions le
bord de l'eau et on est évidemment
impatient de savoir ce que vous avez
pensé de l'intervention des manuels
mâcon ce matin bonjour marin direz vous
êtes écrivain critique littéraire membre
du comité de direction de la revue des
deux mondes et vous avez conseillé
dominique de villepin pour sa
communication c'était pendant la
campagne présidentielle de 2012
vous êtes l'auteur de un roi et
médiatement c'est paru chez aux éditions
pierre guillaume de l'an dernier bonjour
juan branco
merci aussi nous avoir rejoints vous
êtes journalistes juristes vous êtes
l'avocat de julian assange en 2017 vous
aviez fait la campagne sous l'étiquette
france a soumises en seine saint denis
et bonjour alexis brézet directeur des
rédactions du figaro figaro qui coursac
encore quatre pages demain au phénomène
des gilet jaune et aux réponses
apportées par emmanuel macron alors on
en parle tout de suite
ce discours est ce qu'il a été à la
hauteur des attentes et ce qu'il va
réussir à faire rentrer les gilet jaune
chez eux
le diagnostic du président et est il
juste les réponses apportées
vont elles dans le bon sens c'était
évidemment tout l'enjeu pour le
président
public aujourd'hui on va en parler mais
d'abord on écoute un extrait de son
intervention ce matin à l'elysée je veux
le faire nous rendre et ne veut vraiment
de soucis disent en quelque sorte on
monde et de nous parle de la fin du mois
et que je ne devais du si je ferai
d'abord qu'on fasse un tour des tables
pour avoir vos points de vue aux uns et
aux autres
sur le côté opération déminage réussi ou
pas on rentre pas dans le détail
vu sur le l'ensemble de la prestation 10
sur 20 10 sur 20 c'est bien vous
connaissez pas commencer par une hotte
mois c'est court
la nba oui je pense que ça tangente le
passable donc neuf et demi sur 20 c'est
vers van den broeck au moi je pense que
l'intervention intervient dans un
contexte où de toute façon le mouvement
n'a pas forcément vocation à devenir un
mouvement encore plus massif que ce
qu'il était jusqu'à maintenant donc je
pense que macro qui a compris cela et
c'est dedans récolter les fruits en
donnant l'impression que c'est grâce à
son discours aussi annonce que la chose
se réduirait par contre là où il est une
grande erreur d'un taissy passion de ses
parts à mon avis est que si le mouvement
ne va pas prendre l'ampleur en termes
numéraire qu'on aurait pu le penser elle
va continuer sous des formes beaucoup
plus descriptif et violente que ce qu'il
pourrait espérer à mon avis donc il a
momentanément peut-être je pense qu'il a
mal interprété la situation il a cru
qu'il pourrait mettre un étouffoir sur
sur le mouvement et qui va se retrouver
dans une situation beaucoup plus
complexe que celle qu'elle espérait sur
le carnet de notes vous mettez un long
commentaire mais pas de pas de note alex
et oui moi je crois que c'est pas cette
intervention qui va faire c'est tout si
tu allais ou s'arrêter le moment il est
possible qu'il s'arrête mais pour
d'autres raisons parce que c'est noël
puisque les gens en ont marre etc mais
cette intervention n'est pas du tout de
nature à le faire s'arrêter demain qu'on
est face à un problème des gens qui ne
veulent pas d'augmentation d'impôts de
taxes en janvier leur dis je vous écoute
je vous entends je vous comprends mais
on continue à les gens ne sont pas
contents il n'y a aucune raison qu'il
soit content et je pense que
maladresse fondamentale qui est que si
on veut renouer avec des gens parce que
là c'est une vraie rupture sur rogers il
faut mettre quelque chose sur la table
et si on veut réussir et de faire en
sorte que les gens se remettent à vous
entendre vous écoutez pour que ce prêt
mal à vous il faut bel que je sur table
et le m dos dames se dire bon ok vous
n'êtes pas content j'ai compris on
arrête on suspend et on discute mais
dire on continue et on discute et je
redis maintenant on discute pas donc
puisque tu continues on discute pas à ça
souvent on dit oui mais ça aurait été
interprétée comme le premier recul et
donc la porte ouverte à la fin
prématurée calibre du quinquennat mais
pourquoi je pense que c'est médiocre au
fond parce que il y as d'à côté une
espèce de crise démocratique et de
l'autre côté il ya cette réponse à la
crise démocratique qu'est la transition
écologique moi c'est ce que j'ai compris
de ce que disait le président de la
bulle sa stratégie c'est ça la réponse à
la crise démocratique c'est la
transition écologique mais 7,7 cette
crise démocratique est ce que
véritablement il l'a intériorisé
intelligemment lorsqu'il a fait cette
intervention de ce matin je n'ai pas
l'impression
j'ai l'impression que le besoin de
protection si vous voulez quai à la
trame même en fait de la demande
politique qui jouit d'une certaine façon
qui est avant la démocratie 7,7 ce
besoin là n'a pas du tout été prises en
ville a quand même beaucoup dit je vous
hais
écoutez je prends en compte cette colère
qui s'exprime et l'argent pâti en tout
cas une salle à qu'est-ce qui pouvait
faire douter
oui il une empathie rhétorique et puis
il est tout de suite passé à ce que je
veux faire comprendre aux français etc
il servait localiser il sert
verticaliser comme ils le diraient
lui-même immédiatement en réalité comme
quelqu'un qui au fond et c'est
d'échanger la réponse à une colère
contre eux je vous donne un nouveau cap
bon en espérant que nouveau cap sera
suffisamment attractif pour faire passer
la colère mais en réalité ce nouveau cas
pardonnez moi mais il n'est pas très
bien foutu parce que la transition
écologique tels que moi je n'ai entendu
tout à l'heure dans l'acte dans la
bouche du président de la république
c'est un carambolage de gadgets
il ya des histoires de il ya des
histoires de fin de toutes sortes de
chauffage au fuel il ya des histoires de
primes de voitures enfin c'est vraiment
typiquement le catalogue
et puis sur sur quelque chose de très
important qui est le nucléaire en
réalité il ya une demi position qui est
une espèce de faux stratégiste quoi dans
laquelle on réduit la part d'hommes et
on continue de préserver la filière un
catalogue de gadgets les mesures sur
l'écologie russie moi je voudrais
expliquer pourquoi j'ai dit qu'il avait
dit sur 20 ans d'abord parce que c'était
peut-être un petit bilan je pense qu'il
a dit ce parce que quelque part il
change dans son discours il change
l'orientation qu'il a sur l'écologie
personne n'a jamais cru que ma qu'on
croyait en l'écologie est là depuis 48
heures c'est un festival alors on peut
dire que c'est de l'opportunisme pour
répondre au gilet jaune
on peut aussi dire qu'il peut être ils
commencent à comprendre l'importance de
ces sujets et les marins ne dit c'est du
gadget
non moi je moi je il y aurait bien un
hommage aux deux choses c'est à dire que
d'une part il ya la question de est-ce
qu'on change d'avis dans son for
intérieur
et à la question de s'adresser à
l'opinion publique il ya deux sujets on
est dans un régime présidentiel et on
sait bien que la façon dont le logiciel
emmanuel macron ce qu'il pense et
ensuite ce qu'il communique scellier
donc je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose de
l'ordre de l'évolution j'observe qu'il a
par exemple parlé d'écologie populaire
et ça je pense que peut enfin aucun
président de la république on avait
parlé soyons clairs donc il ya quelque
chose sur l'ordre du switch enfin est-ce
qu'ils changent ou pas et donc on peut
s'interroger là dessus c'est pour ça que
je mets 10 sur 20 après dans les mains
utiliser
alors je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec vous sur le catalogue je pense que
le catalogue quelque part et répond
aussi au fait que sinon il est quand
même très perché et mâcon il nous fait
au conseil le lundi et nous fait un
catalogue de mesures le mardi et
peut-être qu'il faut un petit peu de
concret du catalogue pouvoir répondre à
ce que disent les gilets jaunes après le
sujet et là je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est comment est-ce que c'est suivi
d'effet parce qu'on peut pas être
écologiste le lundi et être pour total
le mardi et ensuite oublier les gilets
jaunes le mercredi donc le sujet c'est
au fond qu'est ce qui sauve en termes de
séquence politique est ce que l'écologie
va peser durablement ou être une belle
au bois dormant qui va se rendormir % en
ruine branco j'entendais alors vous
n'êtes pas le pur tard la france a
soumise mais j'entendais me jean luc
mélenchon réagir à l'intervention du
président thabo me dire oui macron rend
le pognon rétabli sf ya hadrien katniss
à l'assemblée non ça c'est adrien quatre
menaces qui disait sa part dont jean luc
mélenchon qui a boycotté le l'invitation
à l'elysée ce matin c'est un peu court
enfin moi je peux juste d'accord avec
votre ressenti ces informations sur la
position de la france est soumise par
rapport à ses côtés la france en sont
bien établis tout un programme que la
cause entendue 12h07 avec une
planification écologique très marqué
toute une série de dispositions fiscales
qui sont vraiment aux antipodes de ce
que proposait en marche et emmanuel
macron notamment dans sa pratique parce
que toute une partie des dispositions
que macron appris à ce sujet n'était pas
dans son programme sur le fond donc du
coup à l'opposition est très claire et
sur la forme après je laisse à jean luc
mélenchon avec un cadenas de choisir les
termes qui les intéressent
moi je pense que toute façon c'est ce
que vous disiez un peu cette crise est
d'abord une crise de représentativité
sert la capacité à croire et à faire
confiance en nos représentants de la
part des personnes qui en fait on le
voit bien céder dans le profil
sociologique des personnes qui ont été
qui ont été mises en cause notamment
lors des violences ces personnes qui
font d'elle
notre système c'est à dire c'étaient des
croyants dans le fonctionnement de la
démocratie libérale qui acceptaient de
déléguer leur parole à des représentants
et qu'ils trouvent le considèrent qu'ils
ont été trahis et qui veulent la
récupérer
donc évidemment du coup le discours est
pas forcément élaboré fin portent
précisément techniquement sur telle ou
telle mesure parce que ce qui le sujet
principal de la révolte
c'est la confiance en les délégataires
c'est à dire en haut représentant et
cette crise évidemment c'est pas un
discours où c'est là où je voulais
réagir sur ce que vous disiez de
laquelle en fait ces éléments de langage
qui sont préparés par des conseillers on
vous sent bien il va pas depuis quand
est-ce qu'on devient du jour au
lendemain écologistes cette peur d'abord
une semaine parce qu'il ya une
mobilisation populaire il ya aucun
sentiments derrière tout ça c'est juste
qu'il a demandé comment ces du sentiment
par la question c'est est-ce qu'il faut
écouter 6,7 vous disiez que c'était
important à ce sujet c'est à dire que
que l'averse personnalité mais non il a
agi juste emmené là dessus il a utilisé
l'écologie pour habiller de mesures de
recettes fiscales n'est pas du tout
écologie dans cette histoire il a besoin
d'argent pour boucler son budget parce
qu'il faut pas faire trop de difficile
qui l'a pas fait d'économie il fallait
trouver du fric il a fait comme on fait
tous ses prédécesseurs avant mais il a
augmenté les taxes sur l'essence
c'est pas une histoire d'écologie
système questions d'écologie c'est pas
une question de recettes fiscales
il aurait diminué une autre recette
fiscale il n'a jamais rien diminué je
parle même pas de l'affectation des
ressources
ce qu'on peut dire ça va au projet
général on va faire une politique
écologique je parle simplement de si
nous dire ça ne s'est pas pour gagner
c'est pour faire entrer de l'argent dans
la caisse de l'état parce qu'on l'a
fallu rendre de l'argent ailleurs il le
fait pas c'est évidemment ça n'a rien
d'écologique et en invoquant l'écologie
ils croient se protéger en fait il se
piège car invoquant l'écologie et 10 à
enfoncer pour sauver la planète il ne
peut plus reculer
on peut toujours reculer pour et je
réponds à l'objection visite solaire une
baisse d'impôts c'est une hausse
d'impôts on la broche c'est pas une
réforme des impôts et donc on dit bien
sûr on va pas le faire maintenant vous
le voulez gens n'en veulent pas et j'y
renonce mais la planète reculer c'est se
dire à ma je renonce à sauver la planète
donc il ce piège ce kit évidemment un
souci pour lui mais que sub ce piège en
ils piègent l'écologie parce que la
vérité c'est qu'avec ce d'espèces de
discours d'effroi d'une punition
il est en train de rendre l'écologie
insupportable aux français cette façon
nous
dire la fin du monde est ce que vous
entendez des régions sa politique qui
nous parle de fin du monde mais
autrefois ont reproché au curé de faire
peur aux gens avec la fin du monde et
vous allez en enfer
et là on nous disait la chica lips mais
c'est inouï enfin c'est un discours de
dugny rationalité est totale tout ça
pour déguiser une vague mesures de
recettes fiscales dont personne ne veut
alors qu'en l'écoutant un extrait pour
illustrer ce que vient dire alexis vous
avez la parole tout après un extrait sur
justement pour essayer sans doute de
paraître assez proche des préoccupations
et parle du chèque énergie dans le temps
il dit lui même qui comprend pas grand
chose et réponses que nous apportons
sont trop abstraite trop loin des gens
trop loin du terrain en outre en quelque
sorte uniforme
les gens disent leurs souffrances on
leur répond chèque énergie et chèque
énergie savent pas ce que c est la
vérité
concrètement moi non plus oui moi ce que
je voulais dire d'abord une première
réaction par rapport à ce qu'a dit
alexis la france est complètement à la
traîne sur la fiscalité écologique en
europe est la question qui se pose c'est
pourquoi quand on fait une réforme
fiscale générale par exemple on supprime
isf
ensuite on additionne les choses et ont
fait de la réforme en termes de
fiscalité écologique ce qui fait que on
présente toujours les choses en terme de
plus et de punitions effectivement sur
l'écologie alors qu'il faut articuler
l'écologie avec le système global la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire c'est
que l'intervention d' emmanuel macron
dit quelque chose sur le fait que c'est
pas seulement des éléments de langage
c'est à dire que quelque part oui il a
un mois intérieur qui est hyper techno
ça on va le reconnaître mais qu' il se
dit bon il ya foncière est quand même
premièrement il n'a pas pris conscience
mais deuxièmement il a raison de dire
une chose c'est que je ne suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui quand on dit il y aura un
chèque énergie pour vous
les gilets jaunes lui fasse confiance
sur le fait que le le chèque énergie va
arriver en temps et en heure par rapport
au fait que l'augmentation de l'essence
est quelque chose qui arrive tout de
suite enfin début 2020 donc il ya un
sujet sur le timing il a raison de le
dire
et il ya un sujet sur le vocabulaire
après c'est vrai quand on entend à
présent de république la république dire
les gens les gens les gens on a envie de
lui dire au moins 10 les français
au moins dix les citoyens au moins dix
les personnes comme moi donc il ya
quelque chose qui passe de l'ordre du
vocabulaire mais je terminerais juste en
disant une chose c'est que sur
l'écologie je suis absolument pas
d'accord avec l'idée la punition la
question c'est plutôt que les choses
sont faites dans un grand désordre et
en additionnant des choses qui n'ont
rien à voir entre elles ont fait des au
comité d' expertise ont fait des mesures
fiscales
on dit qu'il faut changer l'alimentation
et au fond plus personne n'y comprend
rien et je pense que l'écologie
populaire ça impliquerait de l'écologie
tout le monde ils comprennent quelque
chose alors qu'aujourd'hui la confusion
est à son comble - 6
vous allez mais juste aussi pour
reprendre un peu on comprend que vous
tous vous dites qu'il avait ça n'a pas
ce qu'il a fait mais qu'est ce qu'il
aurait dû faire mais d'abord les
français est ce qu'il aurait dû faire
c'est lié au fait que les français à mon
avis non pas du tout intérioriser
l'impératif de survie l'impératif de
survie et donc du coût de la nécessité
de prendre des mesures drastiques
immédiate et c'est donc la fin du monde
ça leur paraît lointain et d'autres pour
eux c'est un discours d'institutions
c'est un discours le média c'est un
discours de gouvernement c'est un
discours d'experts c'est un discours de
onusien etc
mais ça n'est pas forcément ressentie
comme une nécessité politique immédiate
pour il n'y a pas le feu au lac quoi
pour dire les choses
voilà premièrement deuxièmement
d'articuler au fond à cet enjeu qui
n'est un enjeu vital que dans l'esprit
des sd hommes politiques de certains
hommes politiques en plus c'est pas tous
ou des institutions d'articuler des
scientifiques
oui et des scientifique nature oui les
nazis les scientifiques mais donc
d'articuler cet enjeu et une réponse
politique
un sujet qui est un sujet
fondamentalement de défiance mais pire
que de la défiance delà d'une certaine
façon d'un sentiment de trahison du
peuple vis-à-vis de son élite c'est
quelque chose qui me paraît pas marcher
sur le plan politique si vous voulez ça
ne marche pas alors on va voir ce qui va
se passer il va peut-être y avoir
effectivement sur la politique
écologique un certain nombre de choses
qui vont être faites et ce sera peut
être plus énergique et c'est très bien
mais cela ne résoudra pas la crise
politique des gilets jaunes c'est ça que
je veux dire parce que fondamentalement
on a l'impression que macron qui au fond
dans cette affaire et s'est conduit
comme un directeur de la com ou un
directeur général d'une boîte qui vend
un avenir en échange d'une angoisse bon
centre était véritablement l'angoissent
et l'angoissant question c'est pas de la
rhétorique c'est le pacte politique
fondamentale il faut relire machiavel
quoi c'est j'échange de la sujétion
contre de la protection bon ben voila et
la suggestion contre la protection les
français ne l'ont plus en tout cas ceux
qui manifestent c'est intéressant qui a
été dit par mâcon il a parlé des
territoires et là moi j'observe que le
certains gilet jaune l'on dit
explicitement on est écologiste et je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord à ce que
vous dites je pense que quelque part le
peuple est souvent plus écologiste que
les élites
même si les élites on parle plus il ya
un sujet sur le fonctionnement
économique qui ait bien compris ce que
la question pouvoir d'achat la question
pouvant d'ars ne prêtent domine pas par
rapport à ce que la préoccupation
pouvoir d'achat immédiate et forte
mais je pense que et les s'était dit
d'ailleurs de rugy à une formule que
j'ai trouvé assez intéressant tout il a
dit c'est la france prisonnière de la
voiture je pense que c'est pas l'amour
de la bagnole les gilets jaunes c'est le
fait de dire on n'a pas le choix et donc
au fond vous réservez l'écologie vous
réservez l'écologie à l'élite
et ça on n'en veut pas aux quelque chose
sur le fait de ne pas être d'abord on
est un pays où il ya aucun climato
scepticisme et d'ailleurs en europe
c'est général donc il ya quelque chose
sur le fait de reconnaître que tout le
monde peut avoir droit à un surplus
d'écologie à un autre mode de
développement et que ça se passera pas
seulement qu'il était simplement les
gens ne veulent pas qu'on les connaît
pas ils ont pas les moyens mobilisés ils
n'ont pas le choix on n'a pas le choix
qui n'ont pas laissé les gens prennent
pas leur voiture pour le plaisir et je
suis entièrement d'accord avec n'existe
rien et ont bien leur expliquer que
c'est très mal qu'on va leur expliquer
pourrait faire de la pédagogie et que
s'ils continuent à agir comme ça ça va
être la fin du rac surtout on leur sur
400 euros par mois alors qu'ils engagent
bien 1200 r oui c'est ça c'est ça
inadmissible par ailleurs que la france
ne produit jamais que 0 29 % des
émissions de co2 mondiales et 10 bon bah
ça va bien que la france pollue deux
fois moins que l'allemagne 15 fois moins
que les transports en france pour lui
beaucoup plus oui mais c'est donc les
gens et dix bombes d'accord d'accord ou
tout ça est vrai mais enfin c'est trop
facile pour des gens qui vivent en ville
qui font de la trottinette qui prennent
de l'avion de nous imposer n'est ce pas
surtout que personne ne croit que
lorsque l'argument écologique a été
avancé il correspondait réel
natif de sa décision ça ne se fait pas
c'est pas de l'écologie c'était pour
faire entrer il faut donc avoir la
décision mais bon on est d'accord
question du jour sur lefigaro.fr les
annonces des manuels macron sont elles
suffisantes pour calmer la colère des
gilet jaune
vous êtes plus que sceptique puisque
vous êtes plus de 80 de 80% et 90% a
exprimé que non ça rejoint quasiment au
pourcentage près la question que vous
posez sur twitter les propositions des
manuels macron vous ont-elles convaincu
83% de nom alors quelques commentaires
monsieur babineau nous dit le mouvement
des gilet jaune ne tiendra pas sur le
temps long macron essaye de gagner du
temps on en a parlé c'est dresse
question aussi de voilà de gagner du
temps avec les trois mois la
concertation christophe nous dit tout ça
pour ça au delà des mers il fallait
établir la tei cpe flottant qu'il ya
trois semaines et puis voilà alors on
l'a pas évoquée c'est vrai que parmi les
mesures les quelques mesures annoncées
il ya cette histoire de taxe flottante
en fonction du prix du baril un petit
mot là dessus juste pour répondre à
notre internaute lucile sur cette
histoire de taxe flottante bonne mesure
il aurait dû lancer plus tôt françois
bayroux de mémoire dans les colonnes du
figaro lui avait suggéré je sais pas si
c'est ça le sujet je pense que la
question est-elle large et en tout cas
c'est non mais non mais non les cordes
annonçant n'est qu'une non mais ce que
je voudrais même pas une grosse c'est
l'élan quand on est peut-être au vent
les versions se met d'accord va sur lui
mais d'accord non mais comme annoncé on
n'annonce est maintenant on sait que de
toute façon s'il veut avancer sur ce
sujet il devra compenser il faut qu'ils
réfléchissent à ça avant de faire toute
forme d'annoncés qui devra compenser sur
le pouvoir d'achat
je pense que c'est ça le sujet et là
dessus je pense que quelque part
maquereau a été inspiré par nicolas
hulot ce que camp hulot vient
la semaine dernière faire sa grande
émission de rentrée au bout de trois
mois il articule le social et
l'écologique et j'observe qu'aujourd'hui
macron essaye de le faire avec ses mots
à lui donc il ya un sujet qui a été mis
entre parenthèses et y compris chez les
verts d'ailleurs c'est une question qui
est posée à l'ensemble de ceux qui se
disent écologistes et comment est ce qu
on articule le social et l'écologie
s'est aussi posé à l'opposition emmanuel
macron s'est aussi posée à la france a
soumise à eux élevés etc
c'est un sujet sur lequel emmanuel
macron n'est pas le seul à ne pas avoir
de réponse
marin de viry sent trahie a vraiment au
début de l'émission fait avant que
l'émission commence ou déziel les leurs
ne sont pas eux mêmes très convaincant
sur leurs contre-propositions non moi
j'ai trouvé qu'ils avaient une réponse
soit à leur jeu j'écoutais les questions
au gouvernement de venir
il y avait une député de savoie qui au
fait tu faisais un job oppositionnel
basique
en dix ans le gouvernement est autiste
le gouvernement ne répond pas à la
réalité de la demande et ses ratés sont
véritablement rien proposé c'était assez
pitoyable en fait je pense que ce qui a
vraiment d'intéressant c'est ce que vous
venez de dire c'est à dire c'est là
c'est le lien entre le social
l'économique et puis la transition
écologique bon ça c'est c'est quelque
chose sur lequel effectivement là du
coup il y a la possibilité de mettre les
partenaires autour de la table et de
faire une sorte de grenelle ii new deal
is
quelle tension de trois mois elle a sur
le papier vocation à faire ça voilà
j'espère j'espère j'espère à peine
l'avenir ce mouvement est pas incarnée
par des syndicats des à l'écologie mais
l'appétit
si les parties peuvent servir à quelque
chose dans la sortie de crise c'est à
son nom mais personne va les entendre
personnel écoutez vous parlez de taxes
peloton personne ne sait de quoi vous
parlez comment est ce que vous pensez
que vous allez adressé à un mouvement
qui en plaine qui en train de révéler
une crise civilisationnelle sert qu'on
est en train de révéler des personnes
qui n'en peuvent plus qui sont saturés
de la vie qu'ils vivent c'est pas juste
est-ce qu'on va rajouter 50 euros
retirés 50 euros quand vous parlez de la
crise de deux carburants c'est
évidemment tout une question d'urbanisme
d'urbanisation du pays de rapports qu'on
parle de rapports à la bagnole c'est la
capacité des personnes quand vous dites
c'est la capacité personne n'a pas vu
réglable avec la voiture
c'est tout simplement la façon dont sont
construites les villes dont est
construit notre tissu industriel
agricole etc
on ne peut pas c'est pas en discutant
d'une taxe et en modifiant une taxe avec
l'autre
mais bien sûr qu'on s'y est bien sûr que
si mais pardon mais justement quand on
accuse l'excellente enquête quand on
accuse les lombards il s'y présente si
je peux dire non mais si je peux dire un
mot si quand on parle de radicalité par
exemple d'un mouvement comme la france a
soumis ce qui en effet bouleverse
complètement le rapport au politique et
proposer la foi institutionnellement
avec une sixième république une
assemblée constituante etc mais aussi en
termes de perception de répartition des
taxes des politiques publiques c'est
parce qu'on a conscience qu'il y a
vraiment un pays à transformer
entièrement pas en juin de mesures
comptables qui vont ici rapporté 5
milliards en lever 5 milliards
on est bien au delà de cette question et
c'est ce qu'est en train de dire c'est
ce que sont en train de dire léger des
jeunes aujourd'hui je voudrais dire
juste un point juste à regarder qu'on
empêche émane des personnes d'aller
effectivement participé à la
concertation qui s'ouvre mais on rigole
ou quoi fins et des personnes qui ont
pas et qui sont pas là pour pourrait
points pour participer au jeu politique
ce n'est pas leur fonction ils sont en
train de survivants en train de vivre au
quotidien à lilongwe qui a désigné
porte-parole la question et cordes ça va
tourner à la foire d'empoigné ce truc là
parce que là qu'on pense gagner du temps
c'est ce que vous avez raison celui qui
veut gagner du temps et donc il va créer
un machin on va faire des réunions alors
est ce que sera dans les mairies dans
l'est dans les régions dans les
départements et ils vont y aller les
vigiles et jaune essayez vous verrez des
gars avec des jeunes femmes à les
mépriser pas du tout des représentants
va peut être mais c'est des vrais gens
mai et vont y aller dire quoi au niveau
8 gens parmi ceux-là sont venus
manifester nissan a exposé vous pouvez
les accabler de votre mépris parce
qu'ils sont pas encartés danger des
fonds zhu les gilets jaunes mois de
valeurs françaises de ne pas dépasser
les rares présentes est la
représentation
ces gens que l'on dit avoir été choisi
que tous les médias mais moi je dois
tous les médias mais ces gens ne
représentent même montant représente
différence c'est qu'on va ouvrir des
lieux de concertation décentralisée donc
si je comprend bien et avec des gilets
jaunes de lisieux à lisieux de montauban
à montauban saint girons assagir ont ils
iront bon eh bien ces gens là sont il y
aura un ou deux syndicalistes de
représentants de partis qui sur sont
minoritaires et légers jose
mais vous vous le proposez pas les lots
que les que c'est pas un cahier des
doléances qui est proposé est ce que
c'est ça qui pour matignon effectueront
penser que ça va donner ça vous rigolez
cete réunion technocratique écrasante où
on va on va prétendre écouter ces gens
là je les prenais prennent pour des
pouvoirs dans ces réunions mais vont
être rasées proactif dans cette histoire
là à mon avis il ya beaucoup d'éléments
alors je termine de donner quelques
réactions parmi nos internautes deux
bleus b qui nous dit je ne suis pas
convaincu du tout des annonces des
commissions mais aucun plan global ça
rejoint ce que dit un peu les uns les
autres au début on met en place un mythe
axe pour un soi disant projet pas penser
monsieur babineau qui conduit continue à
nous dire que le problème c'est que le
cri des gilet jaune est légitime mais ça
reste une infime minorité des français
ce qui n'est pas faux sur la
mobilisation l'a vu elle 280000 le
premier samedi cent et quelques milles
ce samedi dernier au delà des mers le
problème c'est que derrière la pseudo
transition écologique il y as besoin de
rentrées supplémentaires pour boucher
les trous
les mocistes et les français se
révoltent contre un système global un
béarnais macron s'obstine dans son piège
abscons il est convaincu qu'il est dans
le vrai quitte à me faire plonger avec
lui et nicole qui continuent ils
accusent encore il séries mania macron à
que ses prédécesseurs mais il oublie
qu'il a largement fait partie du
précédent surtout pour les impôts et
taxes
enfin citoyens payeurs la plupart des
gilet jaune ne demande pas des dons ils
veulent simplement vivre de leur travail
sans être assommé de taxes et enfin je
termine vraiment parce que nous avons
plein de réactions mais il faut je vous
redonne la parole
magnum quid du ferroviaire pour
désenclaver les régions périphériques
macron la nama ne l'a même pas soulevé
un dernier point là dessus faire de la
pédagogie vous disiez alexis s'est pas
forcément utile je pense que moi enfin
être dire aux gens on va vous expliquer
puis quand on leur a expliqué une fois
deux fois dix fois quinze fois vous avez
compris graines les gens ils ont compris
ils sont pas d'accord bon après on peut
regretter que je peux d'accord on peut
ne pas être d'accord avec les gens qui
sont pas d'accord mais l'histoire de la
pédagogie on va vous expliquer c'était
le maître mot de macron c'était on leur
a pas assez expliqué les gens on leur a
expliqué et ils disent
non il faudra une réponse je trouve
qu'il ya quelque chose tout à l'heure
vous disiez au fond c'est pas une
histoire de 50 euros
moi je pense qu'il ya quand même quelque
chose sur l'injustice de la répartition
de l'argent dans kill très fort je pense
qu'il n'ya jamais d'argent pour faire la
transition écologique mais je tiens à le
dire c'est à dire que lorsqu'on est
écologiste lorsqu'on est minoritaire on
est classiquement très pauvre et là il
ya le sentiment que quelque part la
justice fiscale ce serait au fond que
les riches payent un peu aussi il ya un
sujet aussi sur l'anticapitalisme il ya
quelque chose auquel il faut réfléchir
pour macron qui est quand même la
répartition de l'argent comment est ce
qu'il veut faire en sorte que il
redistribue davantage lutter contre les
ondes mensonges et ses nageurs
mais je suis certain qu'il va changer je
pensais pas que c'était un plateau
politiques dont le jaune je ne la lisent
mais je ne sais pas quel est le for
intérieur des manuels macro mais en tout
cas là il a une alerte aux fortes et
s'il veut rester au pouvoir il a intérêt
à changer la répartition de l'argent
voilà ce que je range r c'est exactement
ce qu'il a fait à première vue ça
naturel et on passe au thème si la juge
juste un passé que il me semble que ce
mouvement il n'est pas interprétable
digérable et transformable si je peux
dire en réformes utiles et qui apaise
politiquement par les institutions c'est
à dire les syndicats les partis ou même
les parlementaires qui se font engueuler
dans les marchés mans donc il faut une
autre forme de traitement politique de
la faire défiler jaune si le mouvement
s'amplifie ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
trouver une autre forme
cette autre forme c'est forcément
quelque chose qui ressemble au à des
états généraux à des cahiers de
doléances à quelque chose comme ça parce
que sinon ça va pas passer par les
partis comme le vôtre et pour clore le
sujet on va juste écouter un dernier
extrait des maliens comment alors à la
fin de son intervention il a il a essayé
d'élargir un peu
il expliquait que finalement tout ça
était peut-être une chance et que
c'était un problème qui s'est posé
partout ailleurs aussi dans les autres
démocraties ont écouté je crois qu'au
fond ce que nous sommes en train de
vivre peut-être utile est favorable
parce qu'il ya trop de problèmes de
frustration de non dits qui traîne
depuis plusieurs décennies au sens
propre
ces questions qui sont aujourd'hui
remontent à la surface
elles n'ont jamais été vraiment traité
elle empoisonne la vie de la nation et
mon sentiment profond va même plus loin
c'est que ces problèmes toutes les
démocraties contemporaines
honte à les affronter je vous laisse
méditer ces propos on parle de thèmes
suivants alors pas du tout parlé du
nucléaire parce qu'il adore quand même
qu'on continue luc là on continue il est
clair en tout cas on alors il se bat
alexis des monts je sais ça se voit
tancer si vous possédez moi je l'aurais
défendu moi c'est là aussi on est à
l'achat d'émissions journée la moitié du
gué si je comprends bien on a mais il
reprend clairement les propositions
d'edf et ya aucune ambition sur le
nucléaire
après est-ce qu'on peut traiter tout à
la fois moi je me permets de le dire
s'il arrive à trouver une réponse
sociale et on en est loin
après 400 ans ben non moi je vous le
nombre l'attendait sur le nucléaire mais
ce qui aura été très bien c'est que sur
le social ils sont un peu plus
convaincant l'aporie du maquereau knees
pour moi c'est son eschatologie parce
que là ce qu'on n'a pas dit c'est que ce
côté sur la fin du monde ce discours ce
la fin du monde c'est exactement le même
discours qu'il porte sur le front
national et ses discours qu'ils essaient
de faire porter sur les européennes
parce qu'il sait très bien c'est le seul
fondement de sa légitimité politique
c'est le fait d'avoir c'est d'avoir
empêché marine le pen d'arriver au
pouvoir
sauf que en fait ça ne crée pas de base
sociale ça ne crée pas d'adhésion dans
la société
si vous fonctionnez seulement sur le
rejet et la peur un moment vous vous
effondrez et c'est le risque qui est en
train de prendre macron aujourd'hui
c'est d'un effondrement de l'ensemble du
système qui nous tient à force de jouer
à cette carte en effet deux mois ou ou
le néant ou wallabies à dire
autant là je vous rejoins d'abord
vis-à-vis des gilets jaunes pardon mais
de mazères qui était commencée que par
dire euh c'est moi ou nazisme parce
qu'au fond c'était des nazis qui était
en train de la peste brune était en
train de remonter des trucs
puis bon il faudra était déjà il n'est
pas un gag d'ultra droite est d'ailleurs
d'une tradition peut-être suffisamment
pour passer il ya un moment je suis sur
ça on peut pas retrouver un se trouve
qu'il y avait en tout cas n'y a pas que
ça et donc cet argument la tombe et on
va passer un deuxième argument c'est moi
ou la fin du monde
moi ou ou le pas comme ça qu'on va faire
changer les gens il n'a pas tort à la
fin mon moi je voyage beaucoup en europe
il n'a pas tort de dire que les choses
se pose dans d'autres pays que le nôtre
et elle se pose là chacun avec les
poissons
voilà dans tout le monde occidental il a
pas tort après il se met brusquement à
commenter sa propre action et ça c'est
bizarre et faire rapport entre le
déclassement des classes moyennes
justement et l'écologie quel est le
rapport avant une fois entre kehl et
l'europe en face on enfreint un autre
six mois mois je pense car il ya un vrai
sujet sur l'invention quand même de
l'écologie qui bénéficie à tous c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui il vaut mieux
attendre une claque favoriser pour
pouvoir s'alimenter correctement
avoir une voiture qui ne polluent pas
bénéficié des transports en commun c'est
à dire ah bon parce qu'il ya sujet la
réinvente welovetennis par exemple
comment il fait une espèce de lien et
veut tout mettre dans tout en disant
c'est parce qu'on sait pas assez
préoccupée de la fin du monde pendant
des problèmes de la fin du mois les deux
problèmes sont sans doute des vrais
problèmes
mais ces stations de tout mélanger comme
vous le disiez loin les renault mais
aussi les débats moi qui me regardent
qui me regardent faire mon discours
c'est ça qui est assez étrange alors
c'était pas la fin du monde au sénat
mais quand même gérald darmanin a réussi
à bloquer le fonctionnement du sénat
pendant près trois jours le ministre du
budget il s'oppose en effet à une
exonération fiscale de 1500 euros par
mois qui a été votée pour les élus un
allègement qui est introduit par un
amendement du groupe l'est républicain
alors on va d'abord écouté j'ai un la
mainmise du budget qui explique pourquoi
il estime que cet allègement n'est pas
justifiée on l'écouté c'était sûr et
effectivement les élus des petites
communes sont des fantassins la
république et de la r&d simplement
l'amendement des sénateurs et la
majorité sénatoriale ne disait pas ça
l'amendement même chacun peut regarder
et vérifier cette information
touché une exonération fiscale pour tous
les et du mois le jour où je ne serai
plus ministre
j'espère pouvoir devenir
pourquoi je gagne plus de 5000 euros en
tant que maire de tourcoing je ne le
gagne pas aujourd'hui je gagnais plus de
5 millions entre le maire de tourcoing
ça veut dire que demain le sénat
autorise quelqu'un qui est maire d'une
grande ville de 5000 euros d'avoir une
franchise fiscale
c'est pas juste alors gérald darmanin
alimente le populisme a répliqué gérard
larcher président du sénat
bruno retailleau lui même a estimé que
ce n'est que juste cet allégement qu'une
réparation des injustices on écoute le
sénateur républicain président du groupe
et l'air au sénat depuis le début notre
souci c'est pat ce vote est un privilège
au contraire c'est de réparer des
injustices moi je connais des maires qui
ont vu leur imposition multiplier par
trois ou par 4 est ce que c'est normal
à la suite d'un changement de règle ça
n'est pas normal voilà les mercis comme
n'importe quel français et en plus ils
donnent de leur temps ils se dévouent
c'est vraiment les bonnes à tout faire
de la république aujourd'hui
alors c'est pas la fin du monde on l'a
dit un temps réconcilier l'exécutif avec
les élus c'est pas pour aujourd'hui
oui il a raison
moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi un
maire qu'il ya une 5000 euros net par an
ne serait pas sur le même régime
d'imposition que les autres français
qu'il ya une 5000 euros par an donc là
déjà je ne comprends pas donc de ce
point de vue là d'armes à damas l'a pas
moi ou pas bon car maxime apparemment
oui
alors ensuite ensuite donc de ce point
de vue là l'argument qu'il a utilisée
est juste maintenant si on descend dans
la hiérarchie des rémunérations
si on descend à hiérarchie des
rémunérations les mères qui viennent
1200 euros par mois et c'est en quoi ne
devrait-il être payé les mêmes gens pour
qui l'abonnement s'il a bien compris
c'était justement ce que reproche
darmanin ses dires l'amendement il
visait tous les élus qu'ils soient des
maires de petites communes y gagne un
peu en
i télé métropole qui effectivement ce
qui peut pas loger juste sur ce point là
enfin en quoi y at il une différence de
traitement entre les élus et le reste de
la population du point de vue de l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est ça qui me paraît
c'est ça qui me paraît le prince on ne
peut pas introduire une différence de
traitement entre les élus et le reste
des assujettis à l'impôt sur le revenu
ou alors on est dans une forme de
rupture d'égalité
bon enfin normal met de l'huile sur le
feu sur une nouvelle question on a d'un
côté les citoyens qui disent les élus
sur toujours trop payés dorian a trop
ils servent à rien ils s'en mettent
plein les poches
le maire d'alors mais quand même
bon et puis après il ya la réalité du
fait qu'on trouve plus de maire puisque
comme quand on est la connais je parle
pas des maires des grandes communes et
encore mais est maire d'une petite
commune rurale c'est que des emmerdes
main c'est beaucoup d'emmerdés mans pour
papa pas 1000 euros par mois dans une
petite commune aura cessé ses 300 ou 500
euros par mois
donc il faut qu'il faut arriver à
concilier sa jusqu'à présent que c'est
bon on va pas trop les payer mais comme
on les paie pas beaucoup et qu'on ne
trouve pas ces deux candidats mais ils
paieront pas d'impôts sur ce qu'on les
paie en léon l'epec 500 euros mais la
fatigue et puis pour faire vis-à-vis des
citoyens de dirhams on peut pas avoir
deux poids deux mesures
tout le monde paie des impôts a dit on
va les faits ce qu'elle est mais le
résultat on le voit là aux municipales
il ya plus de candidats pour pour être
mère bon donc je reconnais qu'il ya une
sorte de tension dialectique entre deux
de préoccupation une démocratique une
d'efficacité parce qu'il faut quand même
des gens pour gérer les communes et que
le gouvernement qui devrait être le
premier quart le premier intérêt ce qui
est des maires et des bons mère qui
fasse le boulot qui l'a qui l'aï m ils
avaient qu'à dire c'est pas compliqué
plutôt que faire un tout en disant en
faisant semblant de croire que les
sénateurs voulaient à tout prix
supprimer les impôts sur les élus
n'avaient qu'à dire c'est une bonne idée
de sucre et des impôts sur les petits
maires mais faisons attention à ce que
tout le monde ne soit pas exonérés
c'était facile mais il prend
délibérément le parti d'aller l'étape et
en redisant parra voulait supprimer les
impôts parce que vous êtes du côté des
privilèges mais il se fait taper dessus
et c'est un peu normal
moi je pense qu'il essaie de se racheter
une virginité politique et médiatique
avec un gouvernement qui est considérée
mais appliquant une politique fiscale
très injuste et donc ils essayent de
taper sur un corps intermédiaires pour
essayer de se construire une image
rappelons quand même que darmanin dans
la même séquence dit qu'on peut pas
manger pour moins de 100 euros par
personne à paris nourrit donc sur 22
cents euros avec enfin je veux dire en
parlant de déconnexion d edith avec des
classes politiques avec les populations
s'il y en a un qui n'a pas de leçon à
donner
c'est lui dont moi je serais plutôt
d'avis de ne pas rentrer dans le débat
pour pas lui offrir cette fenêtre pour
essayer de créer une polémique qui
détourne des vrais sujets et donne
l'impression qu'ils seraient du côté du
peuple au détriment d'une institution
dont je pense que la droite à laquelle
la droite est très attaché moi je
considère qu'il faudrait supprimer vous
voilà enfin je veux dire c'est il faut
pas rentrer il faut pas offrir à ses
hommes politiques la possibilité créé
des polémiques inutiles juste pour se
recréer des images qui ne correspondent
pas à la réalité
moi je pense que je vais je suis
peut-être all style mais je suis très
choqué qu'un ministre communique avec le
sénat par tweet c'est à dire quand en
plus il était même pas à la séance où ça
a été discuté
donc ça ça sent la mauvaise foi et les
arrière pensées a plané sur le fond du
sujet je rejoins alexis brézet on trouve
plus de maire parce que c'est pas
rémunéré d'ailleurs c'est pas un salaire
soit que c'était important qu'il y ait
une indemnité au fond il ya quelque
chose aussi qui lie à la tentation
toujours d'utiliser le fait que les
français ne savent pas comment ça marche
pour leur faire croire que au fait on
essaie de les rouler et ça moi
j'aimerais qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui font
la politique à très haut niveau comme
gérald darmanin se disent ben voilà non
je vais pas utiliser l'ignorant je vais
plutôt essayer d'expliquer comment ça
marche c'est peut-être une haute opinion
mais là je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose
de tiens ils sont ignorants tiens ils
sont remontés contre les élus je vais
utiliser le truc de la même manière
qu'ils avaient cette pétition balances
ton maire patrice le balance commerciale
à perdre un ami sciatique
mana il adore les réseaux sociaux à
chicago quelque part se venger de ses
anciens copains et il ya quelque chose
de l'ordre de l'arrière pensée pour
faire oublier au fond peut-être la
manière dont ce gouvernement mène une
politique quand même d'injustice fiscale
alexis y avait un bon papier de
guillaume tabard
non mais positif d'après moi norman a un
peu failli défend une partition
politique etc
mais c'est vrai que le gouvernement est
macron supprime la taxe d'habitation est
en gros les ressources des collectivités
locales
la tuque thé local essaie de se
rattraper en augmentant en dessous sans
trop le dire les impôts
là-dessus d'armes à neuf et donc ça
compense dans l'esprit des looks dans la
réalité de la vie des gens les baisses
d'impôt consenties par l'état puisque
celle des qualités qui montent donc
darmanin et la buissière du budget
furieux va dénoncer les mémères qu'avant
cette la fiscalité locale et donc et le
sénat et autres représentants des deux
écoles dit mais on se conduit pas comme
ça vous piquer de l'argent d'un côté on
le monde de l'autre vous avez pas en
plus nous dénoncer et là c'est un peu de
match retour il dit non seulement vous
augmentez les impôts mais en plus vous
votez déshydratation d'impôt de ça
prouve que vraiment vous êtes vous la
méchante droite du sénat du côté de
justin petit à côté
moi je pense que ça serait intéressant
quand on est dans une petite ville par
exemple qu'on sache combien gagne son
maire parce que en fait on serait
souvent très étonné par le fait qu'il
gagne très mal il leur indemnité est
faible après il ya aussi un usage moi
j'ai été élu à plusieurs reprises il ya
aussi un usage de l'argent qui est très
opaque c'est à dire que le fait qu'on
ait unanimité faible c'est qu'ensuite
peut-être on va déjeuner gratos et
dampierre un sujet au fond sur une
transparence sur l'utilisation de
l'argent public qui signe en étant enfin
je sais pas de temps franchement on ne
s'enrichit pas mais au fond en mettant
les choses à plat l'exercice de
transparence bénéficierait à mon avis à
l'image des aides alors quelques
réactions commentaires de nos
internautes
d'abord la question twitter qu'on vous
posez c'est est formulée ainsi gérald
darmanin at il raison de s'opposer à un
vote du sénat en faveur d'une
augmentation de la déduction fiscale des
élus c'est un peu compliqué mais
apparemment vous avez quand même tout à
fait c'est oui parce que les gens disent
ils sont trop payés
du coup est-ce que ça orienter les
réponses vous êtes 61% à répondre que
oui il a raison
clown ou dit sur ce coup-là darmana a
raison c'est une honte ce qui n'arrive
pas à finir leurs fins de mois sont
taxés à main
cette caste d'élus veulent veut moins
payer d'impôts un internaute qui n'est
pas nommé darmanin ce vent juste du
sénat on l'a évoqué ça vient de loin
cette affaire si je nous dit ce qui
n'est pas normal c'est que des élus
puissent s'auto voter des avantages
double b exact pourquoi un régime fiscal
différent
jean-michel ajoute que les sénateurs à
dire leurs soucis entre guillemets au
gilet jaune et du pont tout travail
mérite j'ai perdu du pont dans la sphère
je vais vous le dire la soute de travail
mérite salaire et non indemnités égalité
pour tous et bien je vous propose de
parler maintenant d'un tout autre thème
celui de ses bébés
c'est une première médicale qui a jeté
un grand froid les annonces de la
naissance de jumelles génétiquement
modifiés ça se passe en chine
une enquête est d'ailleurs en cours sur
ce qui serait une violation de principes
éthiques fondamentaux on en parle mais
d'abord on écoute le médecin professeur
à l'université de shenzhen à l'origine
de cette pas comment qualifier sa
première scientifique plus que
controversée on écoute les voir et ils
sont très présentes et d'équité de
décence et à certaines de nos jeans
exagéré
dérives individuelles ou preuve qu'avec
la ville éthique et ça peut devenir
dangereux en fait je ne connaissais pas
cette affaire là ce qui se passe là
c'est donc plutôt de la thérapie génique
aux mille danse est au lit dès lors
plutôt que de là plutôt que de le gêner
ça se fait surtout soit l'embryon avant
l'implantation d'un clic on veut des
rites et à nos projets en vue d'éviter
voilà c'est ça en vue d'éviter une
maladie mais ça n'est pas aussi
d'annoncer comme absolument bon oui ça
me gêne oui bien sûr ça me gêne je ne
saurais même pas d'ailleurs dire
pourquoi ça me gêne en fait ça me gêne
parce qu'au trafic
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de
l'art du phénomène naturel et qu'il ya
une forme de comment dirais-je
d'immensité des conséquences
[Musique]
vertigineuse quoi c'est vertigineux bon
et tout rebond alors le pire évidemment
là dedans c'est la sélection mais la
sélection n'a pas lieu mais enfin quand
même c'est ce sont les mêmes techniques
j'imaginais les grands de la sélection
parce que il s'agit quand même oui et
sociales ires finalement parce que en
poussant le raisonnement il ne fait que
faire avant ce qui se pratique après et
on trouve aujourd'hui scandaleux qui le
pratiquent
avant il ya différence c'est que quand
on va soigner quelqu'un qui est malade
c'est la personne qu'on soigne en
modifiant un gène et des personnes
guéries ou ne guérit pas mais la plaie
modification répond à une maladie et 2
est limité à la personne déjà constitué
de soigner là on ne soigne pas quelqu'un
on modifie ces gènes pour on manipule le
vivant pour l'une des vertus extra
naturel qui vont se transmettre à sa
descendance
c'est à dire qu'on modifie exactement
comme pour un énorme clé ou un automate
on modifie son génome et ses enfants
auront le même gène modifié avec d'abord
alors d'abord on n'est pas sûr que ce
soit brésil raconte chinois parce que
pourquoi pas si c'est vrai ça veut dire
d'abord on ne sait pas quelle
conséquence quand on menait ya pas un
gène de la réception au sida les jeunes
ils font mille trucs qu'ils
interagissent entre eux donc le fait
d'en bouger un on sait absolument pas
les conséquences que savoir sur les
autres et donc on peut se retrouver
demain avec des conséquences en chaîne
sur sept enfants et les enfants de cet
enfant qui seront qui seront
absolument désastreuse et puis par
ailleurs cette technique la de
modification de la nature de l'être
humain ça veut dire qu'effectivement
demain on pourra décider de faire que
des grands que des petits que des yeux
bleus que des puits etc
c'est c'la c'est l'introduction de
l'ojnice mena absolue dans le séquençage
du génome
lucile vous pensez que la communauté
scientifique et même au delà arriva à
juguler enfin ce genre d'initiatives
individuelles et à faire en sorte que ça
ça paraît un combat perdu d'avancé
non je pense que ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il fait sa petite vidéo juste
avant un congrès parce qu'en fait il
faut se mettre en avant vis-à-vis de ses
pairs et il le fait en anglais et
serment et est donc est donc ce qui est
intéressant c'est que là il va
rencontrer ses pairs et qu'il ya une
condamnation assez unanime donc mais je
veux dire il ya plusieurs choses
premièrement on savait qu'on était
menacé de ça depuis des années des
années ça fait partie des films de
science fiction depuis toujours et
depuis que la technique risquée une
technique assez simple pour modifier le
génome
on savait que ça existerait donc il ya
quelque chose presque de st moi je vais
le dire sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui on
soit face à une forme de réalité
si la vidéo est vérifié si lui et nana
existe vraiment ce sens quelques années
des jumelles et prénoms des jumelles lui
et nana en tout cas ce sont des prénoms
qui sont compréhensibles par par par
tous par le monde entier non pas des
prénoms chinoises observent donc il ya
une opération de communication dont ça
m'étonnerait que ce soit une opération
individuel donc il ya quelque chose
aussi sur le nationalisme chinois là
dedans qui était fort un gameplay en
même temps la chine attache moi c'est
une enquête alors oui mais bon là sujet
de hesse qui condamne vraiment et que
vous dire cette vie des airs et sur les
types restons sur l'éthique mais sachant
quand même que le sujet de qui
maîtrisent ce genre de technologie et
comment s'en servir est posé y compris
en termes de d'appétit de puissance
premièrement la deuxième chose c'est
effectivement est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
une éthique scientifique là dessus c'est
pas ça relève pas seulement des
scientifiques c'est important qu'ils qui
parle là dessus mais on a aussi la
question de la bioéthique et qui est
devant nous et c'est une question
politique
moi c'est ça qui me semblent importantes
on ne peut pas laisser cette question
seulement aux scientifiques et en ce
sens moi j'aimerais que sur des sujets
comme ça par exemple quand on réunit le
g8 le g20 que quand l'union européenne
se réunit dès quelque chose qui soit 2
lors d'une condamnation très très clairs
là dessus mais simple
peut-être aussi de condamner une
certaine utilisation de l'innovation
scientifique plus largement avec ses
bébés on passe un cap mais ça existe
pour les animaux ça existe pour les
plantes dont il ya quelque chose sur le
monde tel qu'il est dessinée à travers
cette vidéo qu'il faut condamner
fermement et c'est une question
politique et non seulement scientifique
franco c'est vraiment ça fait partie de
l'es7 fantasmatique du transhumanisme en
fait qui est vraiment de la capacité de
créer des individus plus performants et
7 7 7 6 milles de logis qui s'offrit
enfin domino logique généalogie
marchande de c'est à dire vraiment où la
performance prend le pas sur toute forme
de valeur de sacralité et de et de
tabous et on est quand même sur une
remise en question qui a ses propres à
la société humaine sert qu'on va
toujours essayer on a une brise comme ça
on essaie de dépasser les fondements de
notre société en permanence mais s'il se
trouvait qu'un jour on était en effet
capable de dépasser ses tabous fondateur
qui continue notre société bien là il
s'est même pas se séparer de risque ou
pas c'est une telle transformation d'un
créa en fait là terme on arrive à la
création nouvelle espèce circuit va ya
voir ce que ce sera vraiment des êtres
humains assimilable au no chi qui
existeront et du pc en fait c'est un ca
c'est impensable je pense pas discutable
en l'état en tout cas d'en tête un
sursaut de la taupe à ce que parce que
ça c'est un peu lui qui disait
pleinement d'implication que c'est oui
c'est très dangereux même si c'est très
dangereux de porc porter un discours
définitive sur le sujet avant même de
savoir ce qu'il en est en termes de
vérité c'est à dire est ce que
véritablement ont peu et ça a été fait
de façon factuelle on se souvient des
opérations de communication de la corée
du nord à un moment sur de la question
du clonage humain et autres et à un
moment et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
c'est une fête
il nous prend au piège c'est à dire
qu'il ces fonds cette personne est
spécieuse cette université probablement
j'imagine qu'il y avait une l'enjeu de
précis scientifique derrière ça même qui
leur est tombé dessus et c'est de
prendre au piège la société spectacle et
nous faire commenter quelque chose dont
on ne sait même pas s'il est arrivé ou
pas en tout cas il choisit un sujet qui
est le sida et choisit la question des
enfants et du sida et c'est évidemment
un sujet éminemment facchino bouleverse
parce que moi je me suis posé la
question je me suis dit si j'étais une
mère africaine par exemple qu'est-ce que
je penserais et je me suis dit au fond
ma réaction elle est aussi inscrite dans
un certain une certaine société
et c'est donc il choisit quelque chose
d'assez pervers et il faut il faut il
faut imaginer
qu'est-ce qui se passerait dans une
société où vous avez des enfants qui
sont contaminés ou le risque d'être
contaminé
qu'est ce qu'on fait de cette
proposition le dernier mot à nos
internautes la question que vous vous
posez donc craignez-vous c'est
l'hébergement bonifie modifié 78%
d'entre vous estiment que oui cette
perspective à craindre samuel je le
crains mais pas pour la technique en
soit ce sont de grandes nouvelles si on
peut modifier la génétique pour
combattre des maladies héréditaires ou
des déformations physiques mais pour le
reste c'est une autre histoire sichon
n'y arrivera de toute façon rien que
pour la science il faut va falloir faire
de la recherche là-dessus isométrique
nous dit il ya eu le nucléaire
l'informatique il y aura la génétique il
nichols est une forme d'eugénisme même
si c'est pour éventuellement prévenir
une maladie et enfin 6 8 ans qui lie ce
qui nous dit si grâce aux progrès
génétique on peut éliminer certaines
maladies orphelines avant la naissance
est ce mal
l'ex-sélectionneur les mains parce que
l'être humain doit s'affranchir de la
nature humaine puisqu'il en a
aujourd'hui la possibilité c'est ça la
vraie question c'est une question
philosophique et cas par cas on peut
toujours trouver une bonne raison de
faire mais si on le fait on entre dans
quelque chose qui est une dérive
absolument sans limite et terrifiante
donc je pense qu'il faut avoir une
réponse non pas pratique mais absolument
philosophique
s'il est d'être humains commencent à
s'affranchir de ce qui fait sa nature et
des limites de sa nature et dans les
limites de nature ya qu'on meurt et à
qu'on a des maladies si on s'affranchit
de ça c'est la porte ouverte à des
dérives inhumaines au sens propre du
terme
et je pense que s'il ya une écologie de
la nature de la planète qui est affaire
l'écologie humaine est
et devant nous la sur ces sujets merci
beaucoup à tous les cas merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis merci aussi à jérémy
ponthieu de nous avoir répercuté to do
question et rendez vous de demain pour
un nouveau point de vue avec guillaume
roquette
[Musique]